paid parking coming back to mgm resorts  it starts with special event parking and  wouldn't you know it to coincide with  the golden knights playoff run  then on june 1st charges for self  parking and valet will kick in  there is some good news though locals  can park for free for the first  three hours it'll also be free for  certain m life reward members  why not free all the time i mean they  live here i mean people coming from out  of town i could understand that  and i don't think they would mind paying  anyway well as you heard there some say  parking should just be part of the  resort fees not in addition to  but we asked you on twitter what you  thought about the move to charge again  well hundreds of you voted and votes  came in and it's close look at this  nearly 90 percent  think mgm is being greedy and they're  not happy about paid parking returning